at least 14 children and one teacher
have been killed in a shooting in the
u.s state of texas
the attack unfolded at an elementary
school in the town of uvalde about 130
kilometers west of san antonio
police have reportedly killed the
shooter who we understand was 18
years old this story is
developing quickly we want to go down to
washington our correspondent sumitsu
misconduct she is going to bring us up
on what we know sumi give us an update
right now what do we know
yeah brent we are still getting details
as they are trickling into us we're
learning little by little a bit more
about this horrific shooting that
happened in yuvalde as you said that's
just a little bit outside of san antonio
in texas so not that far from the
mexican border uh if you think of where
san antonio lies in texas and the
information that's coming into us as you
just said that we've heard now confirmed
that the gunman is believed to be this
18 year old who as the governor of texas
greg euvalde greg abbott rather said is
from uvalde itself and in that statement
that was really just a few minutes ago
from the governor greg abbott he said
that the shooter is believed to have had
a handgun and a rifle
that is information again that the
governor himself said is not completely
confirmed yet but that is the
information that he has at this point
that the shooter was from the area
apparently according to the texas
governor he then abandoned his vehicle
the shooter and entered the school and
and using the words that the governor
used there said horrifically and
incomprehensibly shot 14 students and a
teacher brent you mentioned this is an
elementary school for some of our
international viewers in elementary
school in the u.s that means kids from
the age of around five to eleven young
kids who went to school this school
shot dead 14 i mean it really is uh
shocking this number of uh students who
were killed and of course the one
teacher and they added to that fact that
the shooter as you said has also been
deceased is deceased rather and the
governor said it is believed that the
responding officers who arrived at the
scene were able to
take down essentially
the shooter in this case we don't know
yet how many more people were injured in
the shooting and what state and what
condition they're in we know that
some of uh the injured have been taken
to a local hospital but we're waiting
for more details to come into us but we
can certainly say brent that this is a
massive school shooting and a terrible
tragedy
and it's it's just almost impossible to
get your mind around this we're talking
about one gunman able to kill a teacher
and 14
children and as you were saying it was a
rifle and a handgun
it just boggles the mind that this was
possible and we're going to have to add
this aren't we sumi to the long
list
of mass shootings that are that take
place in the u.s
almost on a daily basis now
that's absolutely right brent just
before coming on i was looking at the
numbers and up until last week when we
saw the terrible
racist shooting in buffalo um a local
action group already recorded
198 mass shootings 19 weeks into the
year in america that is a staggering
number so as you said we are adding this
to the list of of shootings that we have
witnessed in the country especially in
the last few weeks alone
unfortunately that is the case sumitsu
misconduct there with the latest on a
school shooting at an elementary school
in texas
14 children confirmed dead one teacher
also confirmed dead sumi thank you
you